heute zeigen wir kalender und euch an
wie man einen richtig schönen deutschen
aktien macht laune has arrived in sie
classroom katja riemann tri tor
ok schrieb einst deutsche kann und kein
tier zum englischen aussprechen
deshalb müsst ihr alle ths wie ein s
oder ein zelt aussprechen
this is really the greatest day of my
life senk ju so much the greatest day of
my life schritt 2 alle wsv oder aus wenn
sie am wort anfang stehen werden wie ein
deutsches wie ausgesprochen
dafür müsst ihr einfach nur eure
schneidezähne auch die mit repression
los geht's one world one to one welt
wann feature schritt 3 vergesst das
englische r das kann kein deutscher
aussprechen
das deutsche erbe bin ich gerollt für
spanisch ist wird auch nicht so laut wie
das amerikanische ist es einfach nur
platt und flach einer läuft einem right
or wrong but for sure ein release
sinking erbaut ist am right or wrong but
for sure every liesinger basis
schritt 4 spricht alles einfach ein
bisschen kürzer und härter aus als dem
englischen william nottwil i sure what
is back to talk about me i'm not sure
what i sexl talking about me i'm sure
hat uns so amin war ich sie extra gebaut
schritt 5 am ende einer verfügen die
deutschen gerne ein oder hinzu
das geht doch auch im englischen oder
das ist sollte possible investor ist nur
diese fußball-saison congratulations
kalender jupa semmeln test of today
vancouver